first there was sex box the show where
couples try to solve their sexual and
emotional issues by having sex in a box
now a show that takes things four
thousand steps further sex Collider very
deep beneath the border of Switzerland
and France and measuring 70 miles in
circumference the Hadron super collider
crashes protons into each other at high
speeds in an attempt to duplicate the
explosions that took place just after
the Big Bang now it's being used for a
very different type of Big Bang couples
with intimacy issues and literally
dozens of other places to turn have
instead chosen to come here and have sex
inside a giant particle accelerator and
be observed by our panel of experts dr.
Yancey Jordan author of the decent
selling book getting some former VP at
Axe body spray and founder of the street
butts
Twitter feed Mick gold I think you guys
need to find the oh god particle and
bang at the speed of light right I'm
deputy director of the European
Organization for Nuclear Research dr.
Morris why score I was unaware of the
nature of this program rather this is a
terrible idea
Luce and Rita achieve atomic level
ecstasy
or should we have taken a few more
safety precautions maybe worked out some
of the kinks
find out on the next sex Collider second
Samil bullet to beyond everything hey
thanks for watching please subscribe to
my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please